je suis extrêmement gênée par la
tournure de ce débat en réalité pas
seulement ce soir mais même dans la
société en règle générale c'est à dire
que j'essaie de m'attacher en fait c'est
mon métier au fait et si je reprends les
faits on à ces débats là depuis une
dizaine de jours à cause donc de la
fameuse agression de michel est clair
moi je suis déjà frappé par le fait que
personne remarque une chose c'est que on
voit les images une première fois puis
après on découvre la totalité des images
dans un second temps et cette fois ci il
a été dit mais je n'ai pas commenter
serre que dans un premier cas vous avez
des flics qui s'acharne sur quelqu'un à
tout le monde est choqué légitimement
dans un deuxième cas vous découvrirez en
fait il est lui même très menaçant qu'il
a des copains qui sont juste derrière
écrit flic comprennent qu'ils sont en
minorité si si ils comprennent qu'ils
sont en minorité et ils expliqueront
ensuite qu'en fait qu'ils ont paniqué
ils ont eu peur ils ont reconnu une
disproportion en disant qu'ils ont fait
ça parce qu'ils avaient peur on assiste
assez peu quand même sur le pedigree du
camarade qui n'excuse pas le fait qu'il
a été frappé au sol mais on met ensuite
ce qui vous choque apparemment n'a pas
choqué la justice et les enquêteurs ils
sont offerts là une aberration faire la
justice mais c'est par essence il y en a
deux qui ont été de dire mis en
détention provisoire non et je veux dire
que c'est bien je ne passais pas
l'extrême gauche qui a fait ce jugement
c'est bien également
j'ai les autorités l'extrême gauche à
contribuer dans cette séquence vous
expliquer pourquoi
parce que déjà premièrement c'est très
intéressant que ce soit fait en deux
fois et que la deuxième fois en
apprennent beaucoup plus de choses qui
nuance énormément le récit parce que
pourquoi je vous parle de ça parce que
qu'est-ce que c'est la conséquence
immédiate c'est des manifs le week-end
d'après durant lesquelles c'est pas un
flic qui se fait massacrer ses 98 qui
partent au tapis des méchas 98 justement
reconnaître des deux côtés c'est du
relativisme moi je vous dis notre métier
est bon en théorie quand on débat comme
ça c'est d'essayer de comprendre ce qui
ce qui est systémique
on dit souvent que les violences sont
systémiques je vous garantis que je les
reconnais évidemment sans aucun problème
sauf qu'elle ne constitue pas un système
maintenant si vous prenez encore une
fois des chiffres
je crois que l'igpn est saisi en 2001
2460 affaires qui sont pas tout
évidemment des violences policières
en revanche ce qu'on oublie
régulièrement de dire c'est que chaque
jour il y avait un flic qui sont péter
la gueule qui se font agresser
ça veut dire plus de 7000 par an on peut
comparer déjà les deux niveaux du rhin
fraude et comparaîtront à chaque patient
s'est bien exprimé les uns et les autres
il s'agit absolument pas excusé je vous
des violences contre les jets vous dire
les violences policières
le personnel personne n'est sur ces
crimes sont parfois tellement les autres
nations se déposer en plus je vais vous
dire c'est pas du tout pour vous mettre
à l'aise mais moi j'étais choqué par la
répression des jeunes parce que je pense
que ce n'était pas un problème de deux
policiers d'un problème de bach etc
mais un problème d'ordre politique mais
c'est autre chose je termine en vous
disant jusque pourquoi je suis énervé ce
parce qu'à la fin la conclusion tous ces
débats la conclusion de cette semaine de
discussions sur les violences policières
c'est qu'on est tous là à se demander
comment on pourrait faire en sorte que
la police soit moins dangereuse quand
même pour les sites allemands dangereuse
si si si la police fait elle de plus en
plus peur moi je vais vous expliquer
aujourd'hui ce que je crois être le vrai
problème je pense à madame qui est femme
de flic je pense à monsieur qu'est
syndicaliste policier je pense à vous
qui êtes policier et je sais en fait
parce que je parle avec beaucoup de
policiers en ce moment les fameux gens
de la brave j'en ai vu deux ce matin au
bureau qui sont venus raconter leur vie
c'est pas du tout des tarés comme vous
dites c'est pas du tout des gens qui
souffrent je pense à vous parce que
c'est des gens comme les autres fous qui
ont choisi de faire un métier pas pour
vous crever un oeil ou pas pour vous
péter la gueule
ils ont choisi de faire ce métier parce
qu'ils avaient envie de protéger la
société est le premier rempart face à la
barbarie
il se lève tous les matins alors qu'ils
ont plus les moyens de faire leur boulot
l'abolition de travail affreuse ils ont
ils sont entravées par la paperasse
ils ont désormais parce que c'est des
excuses pour frapper un jeune homme a
des excuses des excuses vous dis voilà
d'excusés pour ça je m'échauffais
personnes discutent les intentions si si
si je trouve que dans les cas dans des
circonstances qui ont été rappelés qui
sont inadmissibles se baladent en
liberté ce n'est pas un si long car aig
et nous croyons savoir merville unis
n'est pas dans un système lundi
organisme est le genre de chose en
revanche qu'ils vivent est systémique et
c'est ça le problème c'était française
aujourd'hui on va bientôt parce que la
vérité c'est qu'ils vont arrêter de
faire leur boulot
un jour ils vont déposer leurs actions
ils vont arrêter de nous protéger montée
en dhr est donné
non grasse qui se met au service du
citoyen